Đây là đứa gặp đỡ sản trình thắng tay dài anh báo trí thi dơi năm nay nhìn không trong anh lần,
báo gặng tòi lựa xuất sắc nhất năm nay. Nhưng báo trông anh là cựb ấy mà mụt a chô chí tôi.
Một vụ nếm mong sức dội của Israel xuống sợ gà ra đã cức đi đức tay của em.
Thì em đang thịt dục ra đình mong trắng đi dục tảnh.
Bởi bằng sống khảo trong cân phóng nghiệm bở gặng người về từ khách thi dối,
chính trân dục và mốt không nhận trường tăng tóc không nước mắt hổ đau,
lại trở thành biểu tượng mạnh mẽ hết.
Bất cảnh kể một câu chuyển sông sắc về chính trang,
quả nhìn vô tội của một đứa trẻ bị tương đỏ thương ai.
Đây là một bất an tính lòng, nhưng lại cất lên tiếng nói mạnh mẽ.
Và chính dự tính lọc với đã lội của người xem vào tông đi vụ,
hãy nhìn tôi, tôi chỉ là một đứa trẻ,
và tôi cũng muốn có một tương lạy.
Hát ra của bất an là xa mai ở vụ ở nguyễn vành ra đã sành được sạy thử xanh phóng,
mà cô hẳng mở ớn.
Thế nhưng khi khoảng khách chiến thăng đến, cô lại không thể thấy vôy.
Lúc đầu, mạm mốt không muốn mọi người thấy mình như vậy,
em cảm thấy sấu hụp.
Như điều khiến em thay đổi, là hí vọc dòng điều ai đó nhìn thấy em,
đứa cơ chuyện của em, thì có thể sẽ giúp em có được đôi tay ra,
để em có thể sấu như bảo đuổi trẻ khác.
Íc mơ của mạm mốt thật sản dị có tay ra, được đi học,
bà sống của sống mình đường.
Khiện ra đi ngay mở được xa tàn xa cơ tàn.
Sau khi trẻ qua điều trẻ, mạm mốt đăng tập biết,
và là mọi thứ bằng đứa trân.
Nhưng mạm mốt không phải là đứa trẻ dưới nhấn.
Bột trẻ nợ gà vàn,
bá để lại những tổ thương tàn phóng cho trẻ em.
Đến khối ngang hành hình không trẻ mà mình tư,
lây nụ cô ước tính, gà xa là nơi của tỷ lệ trẻ em của chi càng nhất thì giới.
Hí bước vào phùng chiến sự, tôi từ họ,
lựu có bước ảnh nào đủ sức trấm sức chiến trẻ khai không.
Những người dân thường đông có lối gì,
họ không đăng phải khánh chiệu bất kỳ cảy giả nào,
rù là trẻ em hay phụ nướng, người ra hay thành nghiên.
Tối vô cùng biết ơn các nghiệp anh giả báo chi những người đã mất chấp dành,
khóng và tổn thích tinh thần để liêu dữ những khoảng khác chiến tham hành động cho chúng ta.
Báo chi, không thể ngát bóng xơi.
Nhưng có thể kiến thích sời không quay lân,
bởi những đứa trẻ như mà mốt,
những nhân trình sống cho khai giả của chiến trang.